Michael Sam you guys know about him he
is now going to be the first openly gay
NFL player he was signed by the st.
Louis Rams this is a great story it's
time hopefully there'll be some more
coming no pun intended and former
Indianapolis Colts head coach Tony Dungy
had some interesting things to say about
Michael salmon we've got quote he said I
wouldn't have taken him not because I
don't believe Michael Sam should have a
chance to play but I wouldn't want to
deal with all of it it's not going to be
totally smooth things will happen so
before we get into the substance of that
just real quick Tony Dungy was the first
african-american coach to win a Super
Bowl so this is a guy who has changed
things for the better and live through
some stuff so Jimmy let's start just
with that with that angle I agree with
Tony Dungy that's why I thought it was
crazy when they had Jackie Robinson in
the league such a distraction to the
strip it was such a distraction too much
of a distraction Tony Dungy was so
distracted by that gay guy going in the
NFL he crashed his car and the way to
work that day I don't know if you know
that so that's what he said it was a
strack shin and though he but he has it
both way he tries to say that I don't I
should be able to play but I ain't gonna
happen cuz you go back you can't have it
both ways exactly we can say that
fundamental problem with this statement
and when he goes on to try to clarify
the statement i read i read it up maybe
six or seven times cuz I'm like maybe
I'm slow because in the statement he's
like yes I nobody asked me if I believe
he should have the right to play no one
asked me if I thought he deserved and
I'm like oh so you're agreeing with all
of this yeah right but he just didn't
play with you right okay and I don't
think you get credit for the stuff
that's so obvious you know you mean get
congratulations he can play like you
don't die horizon live your life and
pursue the American dream yeah wait but
not with me okay right right that so so
what do you guys make of the now you're
african-american am i I've taken
making Jamaican okay there you go that
market at all wanted to clarify that
we're in America how about that okay so
what what about that angle of it though
that he as the first african-american
coach to ever win a suitable that he's
been through that the things that have
changed so it's particularly odd that he
would make a statement and that's how he
came across to me it was actually very
disappointing because unfortunately we
still live in a world and in a country
where whenever you have a friend for
minorities one person kind of speaks for
the group so when you see someone who's
african-american saying something that
isn't in line with your thought process
at all it's like oh great oh no but
people know more know you more than 80
me they'll think I think like you no no
you know you kind of have that momentary
panic I'm not an idiot I swear yeah so
it's it's unfortunate and these
representative of all gay people oh oh
yeah I know what you're saying well you
can act a little gayer than get up just
a smidge Jimmy tell me about her what
you Hank you now I know when you're
coming from so I will say this about
Tony Dungy now I grew up in a kind of
very racist neighborhood and what he was
he say's about says about the gays is
what a lot of races say about Plaxico no
Iowa I work with them but and they
should be able to live wherever they
want but not next door to me right or I
love black people i worth either but
they can't date my daughter it's that
kind of a thing right and so the i love
them i'll go to church with them but
they can't live in my neighborhood you
look stacked he's say that's what he's
saying hey should be able to live
somewhere he should ever the play
somewhere just not him next to me
nothing like that really really i don't
even do that well that was that's not
even good what is that that's like half
Paul and I said yeah um okay whatever he
is he that also goes on to talk about
how he and in terms of right well how
did he put it I don't want to paraphrase
poorly but essentially he was will clean
it but his point was how he felt as
though he was trying to be supportive of
gay rights while saying we're talking
about distractions but creating the
distraction that he was right at the
same time fearful would could come about
from having Michael said I'm like yes
wait think you're out of here cuz I
think what he's trying to say is there's
going to be a
media problem you know you mean but yet
he's the one creating about so I don't
think it's really coming from anything
against gay people I think he's saying
as a given him a very tepid defense here
just to play devil's a little bit but I
think he's trying to say that yes to
bring in an openly gay player sadly at
this point there's going to be a media
circus now he's creating the media
circus at the same time but isn't this
just why we need people to just be out
and that's it and hopefully this one
thing we'll have to deal with this for a
season and the next season five guys
will come out and it'll be big goddamn
deal and that's it but the reason it's
it's grating for me still is because
look at he's in that position where he
knows that the attention is often
focused not on the game but on people's
personal lives or race or or sexual
orientation so instead instead of with
using that awareness to not channel the
focus in that direction that's exactly
what he did so he's aware of how this
plays out and still goes you know
because he's gay I wouldn't want to deal
with that you just are feeding the same
a problem so she can say to quit yes I
was in Africa they and they you know
what they call blood people there
Africans is weird Nathan some
african-american how did I get away with
that [ __ ] I don't know but yeah I forget
the other things go the other point
don't worry about that quickly do I have
to issue any sort of apology to the good
people of Jamaica I've been to Jamaica
wonderful place I didn't mean to uh you
know I think we'll be fine because you
represent all all of them Jamaican sorry
they say Jamaicans don't be offended
they don't you know this direction when
what's the guy's name the player Michael
Sam Michael Sam he did I heard he did
put a glory hole in the shower room
which was not right so that's a little
bit of a distraction well you know
depends how good of a time you wanted
right
you